c'est une rose bonjour bonjour monsieur
caruge et bonjour aux auditeurs de
martinique 1ère vous êtes la présidente
de la cés pme la confédération des
petites et moyennes entreprises de la
martinique vous êtes élu depuis cinq ans
alors en tant que tel en tant que
présidente de la cés pme avez vous des
relations avec les éditer des
municipalités et des epic effectivement
dans ma fonction de présidente
et puis en tant qu institution qu'est la
confédération des petites et moyennes
entreprises
on est régulièrement conviés par ces
institutions à des réunions à des à des
échanges notamment sur des sujets qui
peuvent préoccuper la situation locale
dont il ya des échanges quand même
réguliers entre les institutions alors
un petit peu moins les municipalités en
ce qui nous concerne mais les épiques
effectivement les opci pardon ce que
c'est on est quand même conscient
oui j'ai dit et pics et vous avez raison
d'ailleurs c'est le pci puisque c'est un
acronyme qui veut dire établissements
publics de coopération intercommunale
en fait ce qu'on appelle plus
communément les communautés
d'agglomération actuellement voilà donc
vous n'êtes plus en lien avec ces
communautés d'agglomération qu'avec les
municipalités mais même si ça vous
arrive
depuis la loi de notre il y a quand même
les règles du jeu ont changé donc les
opci ont récupéré on va dire ça comme ça
certaines compétences donc c'est vrai
que l'interlocuteur plus direct ce
serait le
en direct avec les les opci des
communautés d'agglomération alors
justement est-ce que alors là on parlait
de vous en tant que présidente mais vous
avez dit que l'organisme aussi ces pme a
des relations
est ce que ça peut aller jusqu'à de
nouer des partenariats signé des
conventions vous voyez s'engager sur un
terme sur des objectifs bien précis et
d'intérêt commun
ça peut aller jusque là puisque les opci
sont la responsabilité de mettre en
place des actions de soutien auprès des
entreprises donc ça peut aller jusqu'à
des partenariats et ça dans
l'organisation aujourd'hui les opci
auront aussi des compétences sur les
fonds européens et on est appelé à
nommer des mandataires puisque nous
sommes une institution représentative à
ces pme et nous sommes amenés à proposer
des personnes qui peuvent siéger
notamment sur la prise de décisions pour
financer des dossiers ça se passe à la
casse m soit le projet leader où il ça
se passe à d'autres dans d'autres pays
aussi vous même vous allez vous
intervenez dans ce dossier vous même ça
peut m'arriver personnel d'intervenir
donc je suis la suppléante donc comme un
titulaire ne peut pas être disponibles
et motivés
en général ça se passe bien vous avez de
bonnes relations avec ces entités
politiques va nous venant du monde
économique
ça se passe bien alors tout n'est pas
parfait il ya toujours moyen de faire
mieux
on va toujours avoir un regard sur les
délais le délai administratif mais c'est
vrai que de plus en plus les personnes
qui sont en charge des dossiers
économiques sont quand même très
compétentes ont eu à coeur de mieux
appréhender le monde économique le tissu
local
et puis sur des programmations on est
quand même consulté il ya un échange
régulier qui se fait entre les
institutions comme les opci et nous qui
sommes partenaires sociaux
vous avez comment dirais je vous
intéresser en tant que tel à aux
différents plans que les municipalités
ou les intercommunalités on va mettre en
place bon pense par exemple à au plan
local d'urbanisme et enfin il ya des
plans d'aménagement de toutes sortes et
puis surtout des plans de développement
économique autour du tourisme qui est
une des compétences nouvellement dévolu
justement aux communautés
d'agglomération et c'est donc voilà ce
que c'est un vrai sujet alors il ya eu
le ftd donkey et le schéma régional pour
le développement économique
et puis il ya la mise en application et
alors il ya un tandem qui doit se crée
entre les compétences de la nouvelle
collectivité
et puis les communautés d'agglomération
et c'est là où on va appeler de nouveau
que ce tandem soit plus harmonieux et
que l'on soit moins liaison des
déploiements des doutes tout ce que vous
dites là exact maisonneuve en oeuvre
exactement et que ça soit plus lisible
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
d'efforts de communication qui sont
faits mais ça reste encore quelque chose
qui n'est pas très bien appréhendée par
les chefs d'entreprise même les
créateurs
l'entreprise qui des fois se demandait à
quoi ils doivent aller pour si l'on veut
créer mais vers quoi ils peuvent aller
il faut que ce soit un petit peu plus
clair et il faut que les démarches
administratives soient beaucoup plus
lisible pour les chefs d'entreprise
on reste encore malgré le fait qu'avec
leur la nôtre on a moins
d'interlocuteurs puisqu'ils avant il y
avait la commune la communauté d'agglo
et la région à l'époque
aujourd'hui on a deux interlocuteurs
privilégiés mais ça reste encore à
travailler
il reste encore à travailler sur une
meilleure lisibilité de ce qui nous est
proposé sur le territoire mais ça va sur
différents champs aussi ça va aussi sur
les financements ça va sur
l'organisation qui a la compétence de
quoi donc voilà c'est parfois compliqué
pour un chef d'entreprise de se
retrouver dans tout ça d'une manière
générale vous sentez comment dirais-je
enfin c'est ce qu'il ya de l'intérêt
pour les petites et moyennes entreprises
mais est ce qu'il ya un véritable je
dirais soutien à quoi vous voyez dans le
long terme
est ce qu'il ya un véritable
accompagnement du personnel politique de
ce secteur là d'économies qui représente
la majorité on le rappelle du tissu
économique de lille 1 il ya il ya la
volonté affichée et puis il ya dans les
faits ce qui se passe où on est souvent
pointé du doigt parce que pas assez
organisés administrativement pas assez
compétent sur des outils de gestion on
sait que chez nous il ya un tissu
artisanal qui est quand même très très
intenses
on a des petites entreprises où il n'y a
pas beaucoup de salariés voire pas du
tout de salariés donc ils sont vraiment
dans l'outil productif et en atten du
chef d'entreprise qu'il soit aussi un
gestionnaire ce qui est normal je ne dis
pas que le chef d'entreprise doit pas
quand on décide de créer on sait qu'il y
aura une partie administrative on est
souvent pointé du doigt de cette manière
là et des fois les outils le temps de
rassembler le nombre de documents qu'on
nous demande bain
le chef d'entreprise il a mieux fait
d'aller prendre dans sa poche il se
financer tout seul que de monter des
dossiers qui sont parfois compliquées il
ya quand même un accompagnement qui et
qui fait au niveau des institutions mais
ça reste encore je pense que la force de
frappe qu'il est possible d'avoir n'est
pas assez attention intense en
martinique entendu alors rapidement ces
deux grosses présidente de la
confédération des petites et moyennes
entreprises de la martinique justement
vous y faisiez allusion les dirigeants
de ces moyennes et petites entreprises
ont beaucoup plus à faire des fois que
des dirigeants de grosses entreprises
entre guillemets vous voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'ils sont multitâches
vous qu'ils fassent des fois ils peuvent
pas se payer tel comptable ou tel ce
critère donc il faut ils ont beaucoup de
choses à faire
en plus de leur activité principale de
l'entreprise ses dirigeantes et
dirigeants des moyennes et petites
entreprises chez nous ont-ils ont-elles
vocation selon voies s'engager davantage
dans les affaires politiques quitte à
l'est jusqu'à être candidat pourquoi pas
même candidat tête de liste
voilà pour avoir ne serait ce que vous
aussi des relais au sein des diverses
instances
peut-être même en forme de lobbying mon
chèque des fois le terminer ne plaît pas
trop mais enfin rapidement oui alors que
le politique aujourd'hui c'est
réconcilier
je vais j'ai envie de dire ça avec le
monde de l'entreprise donc c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il y à de meilleures
relations entre le politique et le et le
monde de l'entreprise
cela dit c'est un engagement personnel
que chacun peut envisager s'il est plus
il ya des gens qui comprennent le monde
économique et le monde de l'entreprise
dans ses instances là parce que c'est
quand même des décisions politiques
mieux ce luxueux c'est donc jeu mais
c'est vrai que c'est une décision
personnelle au sein de l'institution ces
pme en tout cas quand on est au sein du
conseil d'administration de la cpm est
au moins en tant que présidente on a
on s'interdit de prendre part à des
élections que ce soient municipales ou
autres allaient rapidement alors
concernant le développement et le
soutien aux pme quelles sont vos
attentes vos souhaits et puis peut-être
aussi une proposition pour les
prochaines années alors plus de chance
donnée sur les élections municipales
il faut qu'on arrive à déployer le nu
mais le numérique de manière plus
intensive au niveau local on sait que
c'est l'avenir
on nous demande tous de faire de la
transition numérique il faut
qu'aujourd'hui sur chaque commune de la
martinique que les municipalités
prennent des décisions qui permettent de
mettre la fibre partout a lancé nick il
n'y a pas de raison que vous clef ou
qu'à une autre commune
on n'est pas accès à ce genre de chose
puisque quitte à se faire aider par la
cité m6 le voilà il y avait même une
décision politique afin de pour impulser
de manière plus intensive cette partie
là on est axée sûr on est sur une île il
faut que la partie le développement
durable prennent une place beaucoup plus
importante et que des mesures
incitatives soient mises en place pour
que les il y aussi des entreprises qui
soit type qui est la clé avec la
capacité de mettre en place des deux
dimanches durable ça va aussi sur la
nouvelle la création ce soir la dernière
d'activité je finis rapidement on a un
souci sur l'assainissement
il faut aussi que les entre les
entreprises les municipalités les opci
qui ont ces compétences met toute la
chaîne incitatives qui permettent un
développement économique et un
développement d'entreprises sur ceux sur
ces sujets sur ce sujet là merci céline
rose le président de la cpc a notamment
invité à ce soit au caddie d'avoir
répondu à nos questions une émission
réalisée par rodrigue calixte